I want to talk about where you where you
found this book and why you thought it's
obviously an incredibly popular book but
it has a literary device that works in a
book that is a difficult translation for
a movie and we'll talk about some of
those difficult translations but when
you guys came across the book what was
it that grabbed us a producer that you
saw a movie in his future well the first
thing is that it you know you just
couldn't stop reading it it was it was
fun read it was one of those things
where you just kind of you look up in
your a hundred pages in you haven't
really thought about it you know do you
just kind of turn the pages and so the
first thing you do when you ever get any
piece of material is you're going to
have to call someone else up and say I
think you should read this so if it you
know if you've had fun reading it that's
always a good sign you know and then it
had this kind of Hitchcockian hook the
kind of rear window of it all and there
was these three amazing characters and
and so it just you know it seemed like
there was something there that that
could be turned into something
interesting even though it was so
internal in their you know their heads
the whole book but it also has an
unreliable narrator at its center an
unreliable narrator is an interesting
literary device but it doesn't always
work cinematically especially you're
thinking about specific scenes like the
tunnel scene so is your thing about the
adaptation of how you deal with a
literary device the unreliable narrator
and make it cinematic what were the
kinds of conversations that you had with
your collaborators about how to make
that work well instead of for me and
what attracted me to the material most
of all was the complexities of how rock
bottom Rachel was and is and the
responsibility to show that truthfully
for all those that have known someone in
that position and I just felt like if I
really leaned into the pain and the
truth of what she was was going through
not only is she you know unreliable but
empathy bubbles up and and so you you
want to root for her so you're not
constantly wondering is she telling us
the truth you're wondering is she could
to fix herself right and and and I just
thought that was you know
more of a complex way to portray it then
then just is she telling me the truth or
not Danny the cues that are listed on an
album soundtrack or probably made up as
the album is being sent off to the
printers but I'm going to list a couple
of cues that you have on the soundtrack
all [ __ ] up touch myself wasted a sad
liar really creepy and my favorite q
deviled eggs now the cues tell us a
little bit about what the scenes are
about but the music obviously he tells
us a lot more about what the scenes are
about could you talk about the initial
ideas that you gave Tate and about your
interest in this material and what you
are throwing at him when you first met
well in the beginning it is like deviled
eggs against the wall because the the
ideas you know when especially if you're
working with the director for the first
time you don't know really what's going
to stick and so the idea that my goal is
always to come up with a lot of
different things and through that I'll
go oh I see we're going to go this way
or we're going to go this way and
usually in that first presentation
there's things that I think are safer
and there's things that I think are more
off the track and so the fun started
really with our first presentation my
first presentation that the music
because Tate was responding to all the
things that were off the track and I say
all right this is gonna be fun in terms
of persuading him that those are good
choices I didn't have to persuade okay
he in fact him I think his usually his
would listen to music and he'd nod and
he's go you go [ __ ] it up and I go you
got it it's like music to my ears that's
just what a composer wants to hear and
so I just got rid of the stream so what
that mean what does that mean
programmatically zeid mean changing the
instrumentation music it's our guys are
more making a darker make more atonal
more detune all those things it just
have more fun for me it's just like have
more fun with it and I did so hence you
had like kind of weird plucked stringed
instruments and things which I didn't
think initially would survive because it
was very different than the temp score
which was much more mod
in adult and you know that was
definitely one way to play the movie and
I was hoping we take it in a kind of a
nastier musical direction and and Tate
was very encouraging in that department
and composers love being nasty their
music Jared ona ask you about some of
the initial conversations you had about
casting with Tate and the kind of cast
you were looking for and how that
coincided with moving the story from
London into New York and did those two
things what I guess which came first and
had the casting follow up with the
conversations about moving it happened
really early on I think before the
script was even commissioned and I think
we just thought it would be more
accessible to the to the market that way
a little bit and you know and then Emily
for it was she you know we started
talking about her fairly early on and
Tate was was a fan and everybody kind of
got on board and then there was a you
know quickly a brief moment where we
talked about you know her British accent
but Tate I think you know speak
specifically to what you liked about her
we um up flew to London and met with
Emily and as you know in the novel
paula's rachel has let herself go in a
more voluptuous way and and we were
talking in Emily's like I guess I'm
gonna need to to gain some weight and it
was clear and this is true she couldn't
gain two ounces if she ate a big mac
every hour she has that metabolism and
as she was talking about that I started
talking to her about it's about you know
you could still let yourself go about
isolationism and loneliness and we can
still see that you're not who you were
and it just hit me that she should keep
her accent not only is a wink and a nod
to the novel but in my mind you know
she's even further away from home and is
probably in the position where she
couldn't go back because she's told him
a bunch of lies and she's trapped and I
just thought that would add a great
layer to it the more the conversations
that you had with her about addiction
and alcoholism and I'm way in which you
wanted to I won't say honor but make
sure that you were treating it with the
seriousness that the disease requires
and that you are authentic to what that
experience is like well she wasn't
familiar with it and as you know a lot
of countries and cultures don't really
use that word they just can't drink very
well so I I've had two experiences with
loved ones and and as a lot of people
have and so she just dove in headfirst
and I think she watched every single
episode of intervention and what she
learned which was great and when I told
her is it's often a very silent disease
and you don't see it and people are
trying very hard to be still and
composed and and she brought that to it
we didn't want it to be comical we
didn't need Otis from Mayberry you know
and so quickly that can venture that so
I just really meant by applaud her she
really really studied it and did it
perfectly in my opinion and do you think
about to that other people in this story
have their own addictions that they're
wrestling with you know Megan and Tom
probably gratification through sex and I
guess through home furnishings I mean I
mean that kind of seriously about
material things and about how every
character in the principal story needs
something to validate their existence oh
absolutely it's funny you know I think
Anna sought validation and through
angora sweaters and the Pottery Barn
catalog and and funny enough you know
Megan just wanted to be liked and loved
and so she saw it sex out for that and I
think tom has just lost all control i
told justin i said i think tom is that
guy that was the rock star in college
and he moved to wall street and was
going to be that traitor you know but
he's in a Nissan out in the burbs and
his way to feel in control was his sex
from his glory days if you will so in
many ways their their addiction and
their their medication was the same when
you were talking with I suspect you met
with Paula Hawkins about what you want
to do with her novel just as you
probably met with Kathryn socket for the
help what are the kinds of things you
want you need to say to that
listen to other kinds of things you're
hoping you're going to hear back from
them I couldn't believe it but the two
conversations five years apart were
pretty much identical i SAT i met Apollo
at the claridges we sat down she soo
what do you see that I'm not gonna try
to do an accent she's hot well what are
you what are your plans I said I really
think we need to learn lean into the
addiction and the sexuality and the
violence and the darkness of this story
and she went I great get on with it and
that was it well and kathryn stockett
said you make movies I write books have
fun it was there something in the book
that you tried to preserve that you
could mathematically never preserve that
you knew that people really loved the
book we're going to miss that just never
work even if you shot it didn't work
editorially for me it was it was Rachel
the Rachel and the novel the the fun
anecdotal self-deprecating narration you
know I thought rachel was really
charming in the novel I didn't judge her
as maybe as much as some dead and it was
really hard making the movie you know it
just there was not going to be that
scene with her and some girls at chili's
talking about alcoholism and I missed
that I miss not being able to and you
didn't want to go in at the voice-over
that's what I wished would have fit into
this movie more and when you are having
conversations with your actors about
what happens next for them have even
though that's not part of the story and
that's no not really part of the novel
do you plot that out do you want the
actors to know where their characters
are going and things are going to work
out for them absolutely i mean that's
kind of how i rehearse a lot of my
rehearsing is in-depth conversation
about their characters and people we
know like them and that's why I told you
I already had my ideas of how they all
began and we share those conversations I
told Emily I think Rachel was the fun
part of girl on the Lower East Side and
you know and then one day her and Tom
fell in love and we talked about that
and and where she yeah absolutely
absolutely they all we all had an idea
of what happened afterwards and the
house Rachel turn out in your mind
everything goes
I and my mind rachel is very protective
of herself now I think she has control
and power but it's in a peaceful way I
think she controls her inner peace and
her well-being and she could be anywhere
and I think that's kind of a lesson of
this movie is we all look for these
idyllic lives that we create and we
rarely relish and the good and I think
that's what messes this up Tate Danny
Jared thank you guys for coming in and
take it all for sticking around